rosellas take a look at the numbers here
ben yeah ellis is working his second
game of the year first ever big league
start and we're set to go ohtani to face
ellis swinging a miss down goes ohtani
so chris ellis first batter face with
the orioles joey oh tony no problem you
faced one of the best hitters in the
game and his three fastballs and it's up
to 95 miles an hour gets ahead and
elevates that one just about letter and
gets it by ohtani for the first out of
the game the american league's leading
hitter in terms of hits david fletcher
147 hits
right field santander played perfectly
makes the grab two down ellis down in
the car two balls no strikes high pop-up
this should be the third out
gutierrez backs up a couple of steps
towards the edge of the dirt he makes
the catch and the side who's retired
it's a nice work by ellis in his first
inning 19th start of the season for
shohei ohtani tonight he is 5-0 with a
1.580 ra in six starts since the
beginning of july you see his overall
numbers on your screen
among the things that he's done so very
well the control has been impeccable
he's issued just four walks
in the last
148 plate appearances he's had since the
start of july and that walk rate lower
than three percent is the best in
baseball over that stretch bottom half
of the first at camden yards and now the
oil is going up against xiaoheotoni will
be cedric mullins to lead things off
cedric mullins hunts the first pitch
well hits center field marsha's back
won't get it into the seats
another lead off home run for cedric
mullins and the orioles break on top one
to nothing that'll get you out of a
slump here comes santander
he was smoking last night and has been
for a while
that's hammered
and he's got another one anthony
santander with a laser into the seats in
right center
and the orioles with two long balls off
ohtani here in the first lead it two to
nothing
why was that guy high angels have put
the tying run out at second base off of
stassi's double here's brandon marsh now
and marsh aggressively pops the first
pitch into right field brandon marsh
having a terrific start to the series as
his two-run single has tied it for the
halos boy how quick those hands are for
brandon marsh shohei back in the count
two and one
for iglesias
spikes the throw but a good job on the
receiving end is always by jared walsh a
fine play at first base places noses
infield quite well gets the quick hop
scoops by walsh first get that first out
of the inning slow roller like that not
a whole lot of time to get a lot on the
throw
with a good skip throw over to first
base by iglesias mount castle nothing in
two
and he gets his strikeout with a split
here we go
here we go let's see that split a little
bit here second time through that was
nasty that was unbelievable how that
went straight down that's his 61st
strikeout on his splitter
and here's trey mancini now with two
gone split punch
oh fastball got him ohtani back-to-back
strikeouts ends the third he stayed tied
2-2 chris ellis is back out for the
fourth he'll face the middle of the
order starting with jared walsh
oh walsh he got him come on get it go
go
yes
oh it's been a while for jared walsh
walshy just like that the halos with the
lead and rating business again to add on
here runners at first and second angels
lead 3-2
well hit in the left there it is first
career digger for brandon marsh got it
three-run shot boy captain caveman do
you make a mistake with a change up i
got my first career home run the other
way this time three-run home run d.j
stewart popped out to third his only at
bat
that's hit well way back in left field
won't catch this one it's gone
d.j stewart tightens things up
it's now six to four home run number 11
for dj and the third home of the game
for the orioles against shohei ohtani if
you're going to go to a major league
game a lot of people if you give them
the choice we'll pick a game the chohe
otani is going to play him
got him he goes okay i'll go back to my
devastating split
he's only thrown a handful of them
tonight no that was a good one
six pitches in this plate appearance
next full count pitch
got him you called it partner he's now
retired the last six batters in a row
and that strikeout for shohei his
seventh of the night jones oh for two
one and two bounced up the middle
there's his first base head as an oriole
jamai jones is on board here to lead off
the orioles seven
there you go jake patrick is in you see
what he's done at triple a 19 games five
and one a really good record
31 and two thirds 32 strikeouts 10 walks
and petrichko will work to cedric
mullins the rules have runners on second
and third 2-1 on the way
up the middle that'll get a run in
iglesias to first for the out gutierrez
moves to third and the orioles cut the
lead to one six to five
rbi for cedric mullins that works i mean
you'd like to have the base hit but
still a lot of baseball left in this one
3-0 no place to put him a walk will tie
the game
and ball four we're tied
rbi walk for ramon arias mancini scores
and the orioles down to two have come
all the way back and tied the game still
nobody out the base is loaded a ball
here would give the orioles the lead 3-2
on the way ball four and the orioles
have the lead
two walks to four center run this inning
and i think bran and i will take it
there is no doubt you'll take them any
way you can get them right now memorials
have scored five unanswered runs after
they trailed six to two so austin hayes
three still out there one down
hayes fly ball deep left field in the
corner
extra bases
two runs are in goodie airs will be held
at third
two more on a pinch hit double from
austin hayes and camden yards is alive
like it hasn't been for a long time
well skipper brandon hyde pushing all
the right buttons tonight with his
bullpen
the bullpen has been outstanding pinch
hit austin hayes comes up with a giant
two-run double now the orioles up nine
to six a little spinner breaking ball
and austin hayes all over this one comes
in off the bench
and delivers a huge hit for the orioles
as they try to put this streak to bed
mullins the eighth batter in the inning
for the orioles
mullins fly ball left field this should
get a run in
gutierrez tags at third here he comes
and the orioles add another run cedric
mullins with an rbi on the sac fly it
was david fletcher no easy out 0 for
four in this game but leads the major
leagues and hits
all the frustration of the last 19 games
should do it santander backing up he's
there he's got it
and for the first time
in a long time as a matter of fact for
the first time since
august 2nd we can say the orioles are
winners ben yup and there's a smile by
brandon hyde we hadn't seen him smile in
a long time and you don't think these
players care they care
you